[Applaudissements]
Je ne pense pas que je pourrais apprendre que connecter
ces collines de papa est vraiment noueux,
alors nous avons fait appel à
des skateurs professionnels vraiment talentueux pour faire ça, même
il y avait des domaines où il aurait des
doubles cascadeurs faire des trucs mais où c'était
possible été au moment où nous ne nous sommes
pas assurés que les marées étaient correctes, il aurait
été plus facile et moins cher de le faire sur un
écran vert, mais je ne pense pas que cela
aurait été le même,
je pense que vous pourrez probablement  voyez une
sorte d'exaltation sur nos visages
de faire cela
vous
[Music]
sauvegardez que le trottoir en toute sécurité vous
sortez du sous-marin commercial étranger - et
je vais
aller un peu plus mou petit mou sur
Ben les gars
Oh
[Musique]
merci  vous
vous
tous les jours nous allions avec une deuxième
unité et Derek Wilson qui est ce grand
directeur de la photographie lui et Phil Nielsen
qui est notre directeur de la deuxième unité ils
sortiraient tous les jours pour tourner des
trucs seuls ou avec un double pour
moi ou je le ferais  allez et rejoignez-les pour un
coup de  que ce soit à l'école celui-ci ouais
je pense que les Lions l'éclairage sont bien
ouais
et nous avions tout prévu, donc
fondamentalement, nous avions toujours une unité en
marche afin que nous puissions attraper le soleil quand il
sortirait et fondamentalement vous n'en avez pas
assez  chances d'obtenir tous ces
clichés dont vous savez dont nous avions besoin
en peu de temps le plus grand
défi était le temps dont
nous disposions pour tourner et le temps car le
temps change si rapidement et nous avons été
fermés pendant quelques jours par
tempête de vent il revient ok nous sommes en
train de redescendre